what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and today i have
two special guests on my channel
introduce yourself to the people
well i'm still in cooper i'm an
award-winning porn star i'm also a
former high-class male companion and
these days i
teach guys how to use their junk
properly and how to make sure it
performs the way they want it to i'm
justin waller
i have a youtube channel about business
mindset and from time to time i'll speak
about women
when forced so
uh
jaywaller on
youtube jaywaller7 on instagram and
waller7j on twitter
so um tell me how do you guys do with
the hoes how do we do with those yeah
like well what does that mean yeah like
ladies yeah like with the ladies are you
guys like lady killers i'm a virgin i
don't know what we're talking about
you're a virgin yeah i'm the world's
only virgin okay well this is so good
because so i don't know if you know this
but sterling and i
do bible study and pray every night
every night every night what do you guys
learn
what do you what are you like the key
i'll tell you i'll tell you for a start
i learned what uh the word peter
means in my last bubble study session
yes yeah peter is an american american
word for penis
well no not in the bible in the bible
peter means peter means a rock
yeah rock hard that's how it got peter
exactly well we had very very different
experiences
uh anyways so i i feel like you guys are
lying i think there's a cow i don't know
i don't know how
she gets that in person i'm i'm sensing
i'm almost offended actually yeah
you can be offended so
i'm i'm sensing some caps so i decided
today that i'm gonna show you um what i
grew up on so i did 12 years of catholic
school
and every year we we saw chastity
speakers interesting now especially for
sterling
um
the the porn thing that would ruin my
career
if i went full chastity
now
but you could maybe maybe he's gonna
sell you on it well let's see look he
looks like a charming man i'm sure he's
very convincing uh but i don't think
he's gonna be that convincing but you
know it's funny actually super resonate
with this because growing up in the
south
uh the bible belt
i mean man it was nothing for us to get
you know
either thrown into a church camp or
be in sunday school and have a situation
where guilt and fear
was thrown at us to make us feel guilty
and bad and dirty for things that we
naturally feel okay and so that's kind
of that's kind of a bad place to be
especially like going through
adolescence you know it's terrible do
you think that chastity talks are good
for women
[Applause]
don't you guys like the low body count
yeah yeah we do a little bit
yeah we do but you know what i think i
think it's also fair to throw that
question right back at you
and
give me an honest opinion do you really
feel the urge to sleep with a bunch of
men yeah really no no because your
testosterone is what one tenth of what
ours is
right so if it was up to you you would
just sleep with one man and it would be
the man would be worth your time and you
wouldn't be looking for sex elsewhere
unless you needed some sort of
validation right i think i think that
like because
we haven't even watched this yet yeah
but i
going back to what justin was saying
right they're gonna emphasize guilt and
things like this a lot when it comes to
women it's not the chastity that they
need to really be focusing on it's the
how to identify a
good man who they want to who is going
to be with them for a while because the
chastity isn't the problem it's that
they're a [ __ ]
picker
they keep making terrible choices again
right yeah yeah it's not because they
want to go sleep with a bunch of dudes
yeah it's because they keep looking for
a good dude they're looking for the
right dude and in 2022 it's kind of a
prerequisite that you have to put it out
i tell you
what this guy's going to talk about is
he's going to try to stop this with
words whereas in the past they just
stopped it with violence if you had a
husband in the medieval times and you
cheated on him well you could bet your
ass if you got caught yeah you did
checkmate it's over and so that kind of
kept it well does that go back to that
it's not just it's not just that it's
not just
there was consequences for sleeping
around as a woman right right yeah so
that's why like the chastity stuff was
probably more important to be drilled
into dudes back then so not every girl's
walking around being knocked up all the
time which in my opinion is the leading
reason that women will get an abortion
they get pregnant by the wrong dude yes
yes
i've said this i'm like i'm sorry if a
[ __ ] really likes you excuse me you
can't you cannot convince her to
she won't be carrying yourself that's
what that's why like why do you think
all the there's there's a lot of like
and especially in america there's a lot
of single mothers
walking around like they kept the baby
because the dude who knocked her up yeah
they want to keep that seed but just but
now they're looking for somebody to
wreck someone dude some other guy to
raise the baby exactly you know exactly
i completely agree with that and and
when that guy has that abundance of
choice
that's what kind of leaves her single
unless
she's
kind of in a place where she can accept
the world for what it is which really
leads us to this subject which you
didn't tell us about young ladies
that's what we're going to do later yeah
oh different different topics different
topic yeah but but it's kind of like but
it goes perfectly into what we're going
to be talking about later i have a
question when you're talking about like
like women picking men we like pick
poorly
okay right right before so i have a
theory that every guy i've told this to
i like tells me it's bad like i
shouldn't do this all right but if a guy
is too hot
i reject him because i feel like he just
wants me for sex like if he's true yeah
if i feel yeah because if i feel like
he's out of my league i think that's
super fair i feel like he won't stay
yeah but do you like do you feel that
i'm donating the wrong way but do you
feel that way because of how you
perceive your own looks yeah probably
but like i think it's like based on
results so if a guy that i think like
could get a modeling i've never been
offered a modeling contract but if i go
so if a guy was if a guy was so good
looking you're like he should be dating
a victoria's secret model yeah yeah he's
but he's sitting on me yeah you're like
questioning i think he's like just
looking for sex yeah so but i fumbled a
bag though once because this man told me
he would have like married me later like
later and then he actually ended up
marrying like the next girl she kind of
looked like me i was like oh i fumbled
that bag
so i kind of but but i feel like in most
cases like that that's kind of a good
rule
i will jump in here real quickly and say
there's a whole lot of men
who are extremely good looking with low
self-esteem
so there are a lot of guys who are
extremely we actually know a guy like
that yes oh really yeah there's a lot of
dudes who are extremely looking forward
right
but so
what you're actually saying
you don't the kind of guy you're
actually referring to yeah is kind of
like me and him okay like we're
confident and cocky and good looking
but like you like
it's probably a fair ish rule with a guy
like us maybe i don't know but
if he's just just straight up good
looking but if he's kind of a bit like
unsure of himself and not a super cocky
bastard it takes a while for you to get
that though yeah so you would have long
slept with him before you realize that
what i would say though is you were
substantially smarter than the average
woman because the average woman what
happens is
she thinks she sleeps with let's say a
chad
she thinks she is now at the level of a
gym yeah whereas a woman that's
intelligent knows
that son of a [ __ ] is only going to
sleep with me on tuesday nights
and he's going to text me at 9 30. yeah
you know where whereas like a girl
that's not as intelligent she'll be like
well obviously um i can get this or if
she's getting attention out you know i
was recently i was talking i was talking
to a girl and she was like yeah i know
this girl that's married she's getting
all this attention on instagram and she
made the statement to me that her
husband better get his [ __ ] together
what that dumb woman doesn't understand
is there they will
my husband and that's what i always
laugh at it's like i'll have girls tell
me like oh i get all this attention from
men i'm like no [ __ ] you're a girl yeah
and you're talking to me like what's he
doing so you're a minimum you're a girl
on social media yeah
yes you're a default that you get
attention i don't understand why gas is
girls egos because i'm like they give
attention to everybody like it's not
you're not special and you know what
anything we don't give attention to
everybody
it's the dudes who don't have any
options to give attention to that yeah
you'd be you'd be surprised you'd
you'd be like you'd be surprised
i'll tell you what i think you'd be
surprised i think it would be a very
hilarious episode to go through some of
your mixed requests oh guys i could show
you yeah don't be hilarious no i'll tell
you would be [ __ ] hilarious but they
must
go through our facebook or instagram
messages from women oh we could we could
we could do vice versa it's a different
show it's a different show
next time we're back in london yeah okay
so this is jason everett okay um so the
back story looks like a nerd he does is
that he we're gonna go like what time is
it 7 19. we could do 10 minutes in so he
did
they both came to my high school and
they did a chastity
speech so it's him and his wife yeah and
his wife and
you're gonna see this the story so top
10 reasons you should never have kids
okay now
reason number one it says you know if
you have kids a large part of your life
will be focused on your relationship
with your child rather than yourself
scary and then it goes on
is if you don't have kids you won't be
exposed to germs your kids bring home
from daycare that's right
microbes are easily transmitted they can
be found on toys and blankets and
parents who can get sick from their kids
you could get aches pains flu-like
symptoms and diarrhea what i mean look
it's true okay like our kids like bring
home ebola in their lunch boxes but you
know
it's good man builds up your immune
system but it it goes on and it says if
you don't have kids you can be alone
anytime you want if you don't have time
for yourself you'll lose yourself but
not having kids mean you won't lose
yourself you can play tennis do yoga or
whatever you want all the time now
if this weren't so hilarious it'd be
completely depressing because you'll
notice at the root of this is a false
notion of freedom but the church and her
wisdom teaches us that no you don't how
do you guys feel about like kids like
what do you like they'll laugh because
he's talking about like the left like
that's what they preach yeah this is
like this is like the yeah the kind of
anti-life agenda yeah that you get from
a lot of
sjws and liberals
which i
i'm not kind of i don't think i'll ever
i don't think i'm actually going to
agree with what this guy goes to in his
conclusion i agree with him right but i
agree with this i do agree with this
because he's basically talking [ __ ]
about what they're saying yeah children
children are fantastic yes and it's like
family by the way yeah family is great
and it's like
you don't
i mean being around the kind of men that
we hang out with now like has made me
really really appreciate
you know the importance of legacy
yeah especially as a man the importance
of because a woman can have like you can
have a baby like we have to find someone
to give us a baby you know what i'm
saying so for men like legacy and you
know
knowing that that child is yours that
that's your bloodline it's super super
important and it must be super
fulfilling i've not had kids yet but it
must be super fulfilling for anyone who
does
and i that's why i think
we kind of and i grew up with this too
we demonized
like
getting like women getting pregnant and
having kids at a younger age
not not saying you can go should go
around knocking up you know right out of
rich girls and stuff but it's like
my best friend he
his wife is you know 18.
and they just had their first baby girl
oh wow which means she got her pregnant
at 17.
but
but i don't know about that he was
totally concerned
the whole thing was completely essential
it was actually her idea wait a second
did you have sex in high school no
i was a virgin until halfway through
college lane
i had plenty of sex
i had plenty of sex i was watching these
speeches what do you mean
it really worked yeah
they did work i was afraid i don't know
and that's my point yeah yeah yeah fire
and brimstone that will do it has done
more to scare children
than the boogeyman you know what i think
i think fire and brimstone this kind of
stuff scares women more than excuse me
we should be actually you know what you
know what though i think probably oh
most men can't help it
you remember being 15 to 17 in that
physical urge
to like dude you would like put the
ugliest woman in the world in front of
you at that age doesn't matter it
doesn't matter i remember like just
sitting you're not making sure you sit
there in like english class and
someone's writing a [ __ ] poem you get
a bonus yeah but no reason and you know
what that reminds me so um i grew up
deer hunting a good bit and there's
something called the rut
and the rut is where the the biggest
bucks in the woods which are typically
the smartest ones the ones that stay
nocturnal that's how they get so big
during the rut they become so stupid
that they'll run right out in front of
your gear stand and that's generally how
they get killed
wow because they are thinking in one
direction and that's kind of like that
that feeling when you especially in
adolescence you know um
that a man it comes over a man in a
completely different way than it could
ever come over you yeah um so it's not
even fair to really um
compare the feeling that a man gets
versus the feeling that a woman gets
it's like it's kind of like trying to
compare the like maternal instinct in a
woman to that in a man right it's
totally not totally two different things
yeah it's primal
primal
law versus strategy really what we're
talking about right now you know what
i'm saying because you know the feeling
that a man gets is the reason that he
will go so far down the totem pole to
sleep with that girl you know what i'm
saying that it's a problem
yeah well that's that girl's like
that that man and that woman are not
like in the same league right but he
will go down there to do it because of
the wiring of the man
she
or or let's say let's say um you were
talking you were talking about like i
won't sleep with that guy because i know
he's not going to stay because it's
going to mess my notch count up that's
actually strategy
because
you see what i'm saying that's strategy
because you're still attracted to him
you're still attracted to him he's a one
percent guy right yeah but you don't
trust that he's gonna stay yeah so you
don't want to screw your notch count out
for this guy yeah well not even i
wouldn't even say i would say it's more
of like the alpha widow thing i didn't i
didn't realize what this which is also
strategy right yeah i know because you
could fall in love with a man and then
leave him because you're thinking about
chad yeah yeah well i'm not like um i
didn't realize what this meant before i
started reading the rational mail and
stuff but i used to always say oh i
can't go for that guy he would show up
like i can't go for that guy he would
ruin me but i realized like that's just
like primal like i don't want to be
alpha without yeah well i'll tell you
another thing that that um happens like
strategy wise
is i know
for a fact that women that would
normally sleep with me on the first date
don't sometimes yeah as a strategy of
like because you know all girls are like
if i sleep with them on the first date i
know that if i were not me a lesser
version of myself she would have sex
with me let me ask you this then do i
know i do this do you ever like play
yourself down deliberately
no i've never done that i do that
manipulative [ __ ] no
i appreciate it i don't know because i
appreciate it if i if i like if she
finds out all about like i don't know
how much money i'm making my lifestyle
or whatever yeah i'll get it like then
then it can have that effect but if i
don't if i don't delete i deliberately
don't talk about that i think that's
good and i'm just trying i think i i
think it's just handsome and charming
thank you i think that's good i think
the problem is now it's just like it's
two written all over you or it'd be two
written all over me these days yeah you
know you turn up in a custom suit and
you're wearing that watch
it it like dude she knows plus she's
been on your instagram
yeah
it's like the same thing that you're
using to lure her in is telling on you
yeah you know yeah so i don't i i've
never thought to do that but
you know manipulate [ __ ] like my parents
i'm excited
after this speech we'll see but the
church and her wisdom teaches us that no
you don't lose yourself when you give
yourself away no a man pause it right
here i want to say something okay
it bothers the [ __ ] out of me how people
blame their lack of ability to create a
lifestyle for themselves and their
[ __ ] children yeah oh i agree it is
[ __ ] that that is clown [ __ ] yeah
like if you can't have a kid and still
have a wonderful life you yourself are
trash has nothing to do with your child
my my parents i'm like from like a one
percent family my dad has two kids and
like nice bad boy big g yeah well they
have they adopted three so um yeah my
parents like they were able to do pretty
much everything they wanted it's just
about balance yeah
time management balance like not being
not being a lazy sack of [ __ ] yeah my
dad's the hardest working like see yeah
why am i not surprised either yeah i
believe that fully you'll only find
yourself through the sincere gift of
yourself you want to know if you're free
your freedom is best measured by your
capacity to love
anything that impairs my ability to love
my pride my lust my ego any addictions
to that extent i'm not free this is why
pope francis also in his exhortation
said this
he said
freedom and fidelity are not opposed to
one another we don't lose our freedom
when we give it away it exists for the
sake of love this is why so many men out
there unfortunately
i actually completely agree with him
saying that because the
i think you've probably experienced this
as well jose
the when you hang out with women and you
know we live in miami we're you know
we're in big cities and stuff
when you're with a woman who let's say
has a very very high notch count right
her ability to fall in love is just so
drastically drastically diminished but
if i
you know
meet up with a woman who's had you know
a body count of like two
well she falls in love with me very very
quickly
and i think that's a beautiful thing
yeah i think it's great because that
for me as much of a philander as i am
that makes me want
to commit to her because she's giving me
that love so quickly let me challenge
you on that though
he's talking to men and women right here
and when he when he talks about freedom
from lust
you know that directly contradicts
everything that we just said
so
i don't think i don't think like i don't
think men can ever break free of lust
i don't i don't i honestly don't think
so either and even a guy like this
is
lying to himself or you'll find out in
15 years he's cheating he's cheated over
he's got a ring of prostitutes you know
yeah yeah
that's definitely what happens in baton
rouge there's this huge church called
healing place it's like six flags over
jesus bro i mean big boy church you know
like these huge mega churches that make
all this money yep
and there's a preacher there and a
[ __ ] the secretary had to tell the
whole congregation
and that's not just a one-time thing bro
like priests are [ __ ] little boys but
more than anything bro you're hearing
about them having sex with hookers or
having affairs and all this other stuff
bro these dudes it's like look at how
big that church is
a lot of everything this man is saying
it's the jesus version of being a rock
star
these preachers get famous bro oh yeah
they're on billboards and i guarantee
there's women in that crowd who want to
[ __ ] that man i guarantee there's women
in the crowd he has [ __ ]
and then he repented
i actually i used to say that like the
pre like churches make hoes because
basically like
as a girl you can do whatever you want
and they still promise you a husband at
the end yeah right so and then i'm going
to just say you're sorry yeah yeah and
then i was like and then on top of that
the preacher is the one [ __ ] them so
like i'll tell you that's actually
interesting i'll tell you a little
information and one thing i'd say to
guys when it comes to setting frame if
i'm seeing a girl i will not let her go
to church without me because church is
nothing more than a sunday morning club
it's a club bro
i don't think no it is it is bro there's
more effect like listen my mother let me
just clarify how i know this my mother
cheated on my father with two men from
church
and my father got a note from the mother
of one of the men
to let him know it was happening damn
church is nothing more than the club on
sunday morning i'm telling you bro in
fact think about it when when else in
that week are they getting more dolled
up around their husband
or not around their husbands yeah oh i'm
gonna go you're working out of town i'm
gonna take the kids to church in the
morning or i'm gonna go to church in the
morning praising jesus [ __ ] shopping
[ __ ] because you could have caught
that [ __ ] at the crib bro you want to
pray there's a bible right there
so i call [ __ ] i i if i'm seeing a
girl
you're not going to church without me
you're not [ __ ]
i'm not sorry
i mean you can i don't care what you do
with your your home
[Music]
i'm just telling you and why are we
calling them hoes oh i just that's what
i call women on my podcast oh do you
we don't we don't call them yeah i don't
ever call them not at all i love women
that's another thing that these guys two
major things that i think that guys get
wrong
is that
we don't appreciate and care for women
okay
that's completely so far from the truth
and then another thing is that we don't
believe in
settling down our family i completely
believe in family completely yeah the
family thought yes i don't they're being
they're being like tied to one place and
settling down kind of like well it's the
blue pill version the exact loophole
version of family we have a very
different red pill version different
version of family and love by the way
so i feel like me and you went to very
different churches
why do you say that
like my church well you were a child you
didn't know what's going on behind
behind yeah but i'm older now and like
people will just be chilling like i just
want to do catholic church there's not
young people at catholics i have a buddy
that worked at the church and he would
go up and meet this other chick that
worked at the church and get his dick
sucked and he was married i'm telling
you i know
i'm not arguing with you about this
preacher in new orleans got caught hired
two prostitutes
and then filmed it
was [ __ ] them on the author and then
somebody came to the church and got
caught in louisiana
i'm just saying like of course in any
organization there's shitty people you
can take that in a business people get
[ __ ] at work like you go anywhere
people like to have sex in general
like like i don't think the church is
special
you are good people involved i guess
what i'm saying is like but i i think
that the impression people have of the
church in some sunday sessions yeah it's
not something sessions so they school
level who is that it's after church is
that it's
that would never ever happen yeah and i
and i and my argument would be is that
it's
no more or less likely to happen than
going to the bar on saturday night
church
yeah i could see that i do think a lot
of girls go to church to look for a
husband but don't i know but don't worry
like you're talking about i would go to
church
but i know that i know the guys go there
to look for women same thing man yeah my
dad used to do that my dad told me that
when i was growing up he's like know
something do you want to go find a good
girl you go to church on a sunday you
know you just
put the chairs away that's kind of crazy
yeah and a simple won't even care if you
have kids or not he'll just take the
whole deal
oh that's that's what they hear here we
got to
they're like afraid of their own
fatherhood afraid of becoming afraid of
their own fertility but listen to what
john paul ii said when he was a bishop
here in krakow he gave a retreat to
college students
and this is what he said to the men
he said god
who is father who is creator has planted
a reflection of his creative strength
and power within man and we
should sing hymns of praise to god the
creator for this reflection of himself
not only in our souls but also in our
bodies
this truth is what will set us free and
so we need to face our fears don't be
afraid of giving yourself that's the way
to find yourself women what is it you
fear
well some women are afraid well
you know i might get rejected i'm not
worth being pursued i'm not worth being
loved and as a result you settle for
less than love and our challenge to you
is never enter a relationship looking
for the love that only god himself can
give to you because then the
relationship will become an idol and
every idol is meant to be broken c.s
lewis even said that every idol will
break the heart of its worshipper and so
we need to honestly face our fears and
place our trust in christ the fourth
challenge we would extend to you to save
your marriage before you meet your
spouse keep the relationship pure
resist the temptation to think well look
i've never felt this way about a girl
before we're not 13 years old anymore
we've been together for two years we can
do this stuff together but the fact is
the duration of your relationship is not
a justification to sin the intensity of
our current emotions is not an
indication of the destiny of that
relationship in fact the longer you've
been for with someone the more intensely
you feel in love the more invested you
should be to lead this person to heaven
it's not about following all these rules
so you don't go to hell it's about
wanting heaven for the person that you
love amen
and so
we need
to realize
that christ wants to come into this
relationship to enable us to love each
other better and this is why pope john
paul ii said chastity can only be
thought of in association with the
virtue of love it frees us to love and
it frees us to know if we're being loved
perfect example i was speaking at a
public high school in texas and after
the talk a girl came to me and she's
dating this controlling abusive older
guy that treats her like garbage i said
sweetheart you deserve a lot better
break up with him
she said i can't break up with him i've
given him everything i said look i
understand just tell him you're gonna do
no more sexual stuff with him and see
what happens she said okay i'll try that
she took her necklace off and gave it to
me she said he makes me wear this he's
so possessive i said okay i'll throw it
away for you and she left
five minutes later she came back she
said i dumped him i said that was quick
she said yeah i told him no more sex he
slammed it right starting with
god
a lot of men
find themselves infuriated by the fact
that they did everything right
they
went to church every sunday they did it
right by the book and then they get
cheated on or they get divorced and they
lose half their [ __ ]
and they put all their trouble my father
did this to put all his trust in god
all of it
and
literally
just all he did was get cheated on had
to marry my mom twice she took him
through custody court damn near bankrupt
him trying to take us away from him like
not being able to see him charge him
with sexual molestation like the whole
[ __ ] nine have my stepdad sneak them
jump them in front of us on christmas in
the front yard like dude the whole
[ __ ] thing
and he had all his trust in god
and he got let down
and that's why i'm so adamant i didn't
mean to cut you away i apologize but i
know this firsthand for a fact i have
literally seen it and so yeah he's dead
on except for the fact that
god even especially god
finds men
in in a scenario where they're
i don't know what he said like their god
has let them down
so so question if you notice when he was
talking how when the woman like when
they're talking about the girl she's
always the victim
like like even when he's talking about
it in the speech he's saying things like
oh she's just afraid of not being loved
or like dead
right but i'm like sometimes like they
just like they're horny like
they want to have sex too
and i feel like in church like they a
lot of times they take all the
accountability off the women oh
absolutely ending up in like bad
situations right well i mean
in all fairness i think that
christianity is the reason society
exists yeah we wouldn't even go to make
this video without christianity um yeah
because the fear that was pushed into us
like we were really acting like a bunch
of [ __ ] monkeys
and we used fear and religion and a god
to get our [ __ ] together well
the way i look at christianity is like
because christianity exploded throughout
europe right that's where it kind of
that's where that's where it got its
foothold right
europe who were the europeans before
christianity kind of had a foothold a
bunch of [ __ ] barbarians germanic
tribes vikings like the english they
were [ __ ] mental
right yet all these dudes like waging
war with each other going like battling
raping and pilgrim and [ __ ] right then
christianity comes along
and it's like this
direct like a guiding force you know
like imagine you have like i think
that's this energy in one direction this
is an analogy i gave you before imagine
like we were talking about this
overnight yeah like
sprinkling like a bunch of gunpowder all
over the ground and then lighting it on
fire it's like a little crackle
everywhere right but you put that same
gunpowder into a barrel
and you can direct something in in a
direction so christianity is like this
thing that kind of
puts consolidated it tampers all these
kind of base instincts of man
and then channels it into civilization
and family instead
but the problem is
that that doesn't work
without the barbarian nature behind it
without the gun power which goes which
we don't have any more it also goes to
what i always say is that
every man
man invents builds and maintains
everything in this world okay
every man gets out of out of bed every
morning
in pursuit
of a woman so he goes to work and lays
brick or he invents a uh airplane or he
invents the internet or an iphone or
whatever
that at the end of the day that drive
that force that's coming out of him
is testosterone and that testosterone is
driving him towards reproduction okay
without doubt that's the reason that's
the reason i still get out of bed every
morning he gets out of bed every morning
the end
there's no doubt about that so
what he's saying is absolutely true now
what i do also think about christianity
that's very interesting to me is right
after all the raping in pillaging there
was this time and you might know this
more than me where
um having multiple wives or like one guy
at the top mostly got all the women and
what i think what i think create
christianity really fixed is that now in
exchange for your work and that life
energy we will give you a want everyone
is guaranteed you are guaranteed a woman
now which keeps everybody working yeah
and it stops
it needs a group of men to work yeah but
if they get laid they don't get any
[ __ ]
yeah they're gonna get angry i'm gonna
tell you right now if i couldn't get
[ __ ] anymore i would just lay up i
might start smoking weed every day and
playing video games bro why why why
why you get nothing at the end like i'm
gonna go through all this stress for
what
money to do what to do what why do men
want money what is the point where's the
ant what's the problem
i mean i'd be wanting to get chipotle
every day and just oh no but here's the
thing though here's the thing though if
that's what i wanted
then i could simply like move out in the
middle of the mountains and in montana
and go deer hunting every day and plant
a little corn and be straight or i could
just live off the government yeah uh so
you're like your primary motivation in
like building something is every man is
is to
is for like women to get the highest
quality woman you can or like multiple
wives it's not like
it's not a logical yeah it's not yeah
it's not like you know that internally
it's that it's the same because this is
the same drive yeah you don't have like
a vision board of it or anything yeah
yeah
that's where it's coming from though
it's like seated in us i just wonder
because a lot of times i feel like i
naturally like i'm very creative and so
when i am doing something i just like
building stuff but that's like a very
masculine like thing i think so i always
wonder like why that is because why are
you like building things no like like a
lot of the stuff i like is just very
masculine like the space in youtube in
what way and like i don't know um i
always think of like girls that will
start companies are usually very like
masculine you know what i mean and like
i'm starting like a business now so i
just
i always wonder like if like women have
a natural inclination to like build [ __ ]
like the same way men do i don't think
that yeah it's not comparable i think
it's a hustle culture i think it's part
of the times i think it's like the bad
[ __ ] yeah um narrative i don't think
it's like
you're also in a position within a
society now where you kind of have to do
something for yourself yeah because you
know men can get [ __ ] all the time well
and and you know every one of the clock
hundreds of years ago you did you
weren't able to work or get an education
yeah so it's like okay you have to
depend upon your father yeah until you
have a husband yeah right i still do
kind of i run everything through my dad
as you should
literally like every business decision i
make i i think my dad like wishes i
called him less i think that's beautiful
not for him he's like why are you
calling me again
his locker shut he threw a book at me he
said where's your necklace
she said i gave it to the chastity guy
um
but
give it up you see what happened though
is
she she tested his love like do you love
me do you want me or do you only want
the pleasure that you're getting at my
expense because the fact is what you win
a person with is what you keep him with
if you win him with pleasure here's the
problem pleasure is repeatable they can
get that from others from the internet
from the world but the fact is the human
person is unrepeatable so if you win him
with who you are the relationship is
more likely to last and to practice this
chastity as you get closer to marriage
don't live together before marriage
people say oh we gotta live together you
gotta know if you're compatible man
trust me on this one if you're a guy and
she's a girl you are not compatible i
figured that out like five days into
marriage man look think about it
where does the word compatible come from
combat compatible comes from latin
compati which means to suffer
with lasting marriages aren't because
you fit so perfectly
lasting marriages is because you're
willing to work at your marriage when
marriage gets tough that's what makes
marriages last and don't think of
chastity yeah and
don't think of chastity is something you
practice until you get married no
chastity holds marriages together that
reverence you have for the gift of
sexuality the understanding that our
children are the supreme gift of
marriage and if we need to plant our
kids we listen to the church we use
natural family planning and what they
taught me is my wife's body is perfect
she doesn't need drugs she doesn't need
chemicals she doesn't need barriers you
know what my wife's body needs is to be
understood and if we can understand her
body then instead of suppressing it with
chemicals to conform to our desires we
can form our desires to the perfect way
that god has already created her body
this is sexual liberation
and this
this beauty
this richness of the church's teachings
is what sets us free i just watched a
dvd flying out here that the knights of
columbus did on pope john paul ii
liberating a continent a great dvd watch
it and in it someone said that in a
private conversation pope john paul ii
was asked that if the scriptures were
all taken away and you could only
salvage one verse from the bible what
would the verse be
without missing a beat he said and the
truth will set you free and if you feel
you've been enslaved by lies for long
enough and you think oh my goodness i've
already made all these mistakes the
truth is that he makes all things new
and to prove it to you having come with
me is my bride crystalina so please give
her a warm welcome come on up huh so in
about two years
any american or any western man at about
two years of dating a woman in adulthood
you start to like
like her friend comes over her dad has
something to say when you go put a ring
on it boy yeah yeah oh yeah oh yeah but
but we can't [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out so would you guys wait
for a marriage for a virgin
well i wouldn't get married
oh so you guys won't ever get married
well i'll have i'll have kids and i'll
have i'll have women i love but because
what's more important getting married or
having a family that's loving it okay
because because i i know what that
experience is like i know what's on the
other end of it have you been and
what if they changed the laws would you
guys then consider well okay let me tell
you here's the reason here's the bargain
that marriage was supposed to supposed
to guarantee it was supposed to
guaranties back to my point before about
when christianity kind of took over
europe
it basically guaranteed okay
you are going to commit yourself to this
one woman
you are 100
guaranteed
autonomy over your family
and that that kid will be yours and if
it ain't
then her life is literally in your hands
that was the deal okay that deal has
been broken a long long time long time
ago so where is the benefit from actual
legitimate legal marriage to a man in
the west it does not exist i'll tell you
where the benefit is the benefit is for
consumerism
30 to 50 to 100 to 250 thousand dollar
weddings
gender reveal parties yeah i mean and
i'm all about having kids and stuff like
that with family but it's the
commercialism yeah and marriage that
really keeps it going because i don't i
don't really find it could be very
they're religious but they're not true
it keeps society reinforcing the
audience i just think it's like better
for families to be in like a lifelong
commitment
about that don't disagree with that
you can change your name you can be in a
lifelong commitment with a woman yeah i
don't need the government getting
involved with the
paper
yeah i mean i i hear that
yeah buy a ring do the whole nine yeah
well i think i have a certain i could
get better ceremonies yeah i could get
behind like getting the government out
like i'm more conservative so i could
like start getting the government out of
it but i just think like as a girl like
i would have a hard time being with a
guy that like wouldn't want to get
married because you see that as you see
the marriage as this
be-all end-all symbol of his commitment
no i just see it as something that
worked well for my parents they had 10
kids and like built a multi-million
dollar business based off of their
marriage so yeah i just see what worked
for them yeah but time out but here's
the thing though your father
building a multi-million dollar business
is a one percenter
well he wasn't when they started and
like my mom helped it doesn't matter
he was a one percenter when he had
nothing
you see
and so
he probably has a one percent marriage
as well because he's probably a one
percent man yeah
you see he's he's probably taking advice
from him today yeah he's the exception
he is the exception to the rule
and
and obviously good role model but it's
incredible but
like he the vast majority of marriages
just aren't that good in all fairness
how old your father
uh my dad's 50
55. so he grew up in a zeitgeist where
that was the only answer
if your father was 35 and had abundance
of choice he's probably tall because
you're tall
tall handsome
made money
abundance of choice and had instagram on
his phone yeah i would challenge you
that your father would not be able to do
it in 2022.
and i mean that in no disrespect no i
just my dad doesn't like my dad's just
different like he doesn't drink he
doesn't stop
social media like my dad's just like the
type of guy that doesn't like live that
life
like he just is the type of guy to like
get a wife
what i'm saying is like his morals and
values or he was from the time yeah or
are time driven yeah so like you know
how you always hear people like these
kids today and blah blah blah i always
disagree with that no matter who says it
even if i say it about younger people
younger than me because you have to
understand that
each generation has what robert greene
calls in the laws of human nature as
zeitgeist and that's from 15 to 20 years
we all kind of believe in the same
things kind of see the world the same
way like the same architecture style
movies etc based off when we were born
so
i think there's a huge difference
between being born like let's say 1986
and like 1993
huge because what happened in the middle
of our psychics was internet yeah yeah
and then instagram yeah and so what i
always say to people that are talking
bad about that generation right behind
them is that generation right behind you
has a whole different set of problems
than you've ever experienced
you know what i'm saying that's true
like my father would be like well son
don't you think you just want to get one
woman and get married and i'm like dad
i'll open my instagram like
in my inbox he's like
well
i mean what are you going to say you
know what i'm saying because if you'd
have been sitting in oxford mississippi
farming cotton in his tractor and he had
a cell phone which he did not have a
cell phone and you look down he's like
well that instagram model wants me like
like he would have been like but it's
also the situations you choose to put
yourself in so like like you know for
example like like women are hypergamous
right yeah and if if i wanted like i
could put myself in like like situations
where i'm drunk and like i could you
know sleep with like the highest value
or like and you know guy i could sleep
with right but that's a strategy no it's
not a strategy you just choose like not
to like put your like i just choose not
to put myself in certain situations that
like i think could lead to something bad
and i feel like that's like like part of
but what does that have to do with the
choice because all you're doing is
making the choice way over here instead
of when it actually could have gone down
it's a preemptive choice it's the same
reason i would like to well if a girl
cheated on me ever it was like oh it's
cause i was drunk no but you got drunk
knowing
that that's right
right that's what i'm saying like i i'm
i'm not saying i'm saying you like
people have different values based on
like what situations they put themselves
in so even a guy like yeah he could have
the urge the natural urge to like screw
as many girls as possible but he like
certain guys choose not to put
themselves in those situations the same
way girls have the natural urge to sleep
with the highest value guy they possibly
can but you don't but you don't put
yourself in certain situations right i'm
glad you said that because a lot of
times as a man
i
like let me how do i put this to you
sometimes i don't even like walking
around miami because it tortures a man
to see so much titty and ass
so if it were up to me i would not see
those women like i would literally they
would like disappear from my
consciousness i've said this a million
times if i could if i could push a
button and fall absolutely in love
with an 800 pound
unattractive woman
i would hit the button because i think
my net worth would go off the roof and
i'd have true happiness because i was
already in love it wouldn't matter yeah
yeah
this guy he's actually using jesus to
supplement and make himself feel better
you know saying and i think as humans we
do that we we take some morals and
batteries and we can help justify and
calm like feelings we have
like but if this dude could get
the women that are in his phone
he put the bible down
and fly to miami but i think it's just
like this again the situations you
choose like because you don't no one has
to have social media
you know like so that's that's a choice
right so and like putting yourself in
situations where you're going to be
tempted is a choice so i think a lot of
church culture isn't necessarily saying
like men well i don't agree with 100 but
the way i look at church culture is like
not that men don't have that urge they
definitely do but like
you can put yourself in situations to
give you the outcome that you want
so if a guy wants to be monogamous like
he can put himself in situations where
he's not tempted yeah and like that's
one of the things i think like my
parents but he also isn't i'm sorry go
ahead no it's it's uh one of the things
i think my parents like marriage has
like lasted so long is like neither of
them drank and they both like don't have
social media really so it's like i just
think they keep themselves out of
situations i guess i'm just arguing is
that yeah sometimes you removing
temptation
is a person's strategy oh yeah should
not fulfill an urge yeah for sure i
don't keep sugar in the house
oh yeah but i [ __ ] love some sugar
and i want some yeah right me too and
that's my only point yes okay yeah i
like ice cream that's like my thing okay
wait besties
okay we should
go to where the girl talks
okay so because there's there's two
organizations here in the background in
the background let me ask this
uh before you play it i want to ask
because i could see there was two things
one was like chastity for life.org or
something and the other one was like
something like women are new or
something
i'm gonna go out on them and guess
that the second one is something about
like being a born-again virgin
and women like who were hoe and around
who were trying am i correct in that
assumption
is that the organization well that's
that's what they care i'm going to just
show you the girls part i think sell
this [ __ ] a mile away i think this is
hello everyone
okay hello world youth day
okay now most of my life
i never really felt enough
i wasn't pretty enough i wasn't smart
enough i wasn't lovable enough and at a
very young age my father left
and i really didn't know him all of my
life actually haven't known him
and with that i learned that love
doesn't last and i learned that at a
very young age and that translated into
my relationships in high school and i
ended up losing my virginity and i was
15 thinking i was gonna find love this
is it this is love
and
i was very broken
i felt very used
and
after a while
i got into partying i got into the
drinking you name it i was into it and i
took everything the world had to offer
and i was left with nothing but my own
slavery to my own sin
my wounds and my own disgust and i
thought well it's too late right
what's done is done
i can never go back
and after a while of living this crazy
lifestyle my mother
she comes up to me and she says
crystalina there's a chastity talk and
you're going to it i laughed at her i
said no i'm not going to some chastity
talk ha
and she says you're going if you like it
or not and i thought okay i don't want
to lose my car for the weekend i'll go
to her little talk i'll sit for 15
minutes i'm out of there i got places to
go people to see
and in that 15 minutes that i thought i
was going to sit there god had just
changed my life
there was a guy who's very honest blunt
and real
he talked about all of the girls all the
sex all the pornography everything that
he had been into he just laid it out
and i felt like he had walked through my
life and he had grabbed my hand out of
that audience and he could see the
things i was most ashamed of in hiding
and i thought what's the difference
he's done the same exact things i've
done and i just watched him
and he just had this peace and this joy
in this confidence that he carried about
himself that i didn't see that in my
friends the places i went to the guys
that i was dating
but he had one quality above all of them
that i wanted more than anything
and it's that he wasn't ashamed of
himself
i sat in my seat trying to find one day
that i hadn't been ashamed of myself and
i couldn't find one
a single day of just true peace and joy
not worried what i had done prior that
night pray that we're
always worried but never any peace
and i realized in that moment i needed
to get my standards out of the gutter
and raise them as high as i possibly
could and start respecting my body and
start respecting god
now granted i didn't become a saint
overnight but i had a massive conversion
and all of the sexual sins in my life
completely came to a screeching halt
now i got into missionary work and
eventually ended up meeting jason and
three years later we got married
now when we got married i had this
misconception that all of my baggage all
of my wounds i was gonna leave outside
of the church and walk down that aisle
and we would live happily ever after
little fairy tale right imagine for one
moment that when i heard that guy
i would say and i had my conversion i
said oh that's cute that's sweet but you
know not right now i'm having too much
fun maybe later i'll i'll turn my life
around
imagine if i would have said that
i know with all of my heart
my nine children now never would have
come into existence we have two babies
in heaven
i know with all my heart i never would
have married jason he probably would
have wanted to counsel me not marry me
when i met him
and i know
without a shadow of a doubt i wouldn't
be standing here talking to you today if
i didn't give jesus that yes
and in some way shape or form jesus is
asking you
come to me will you love me will you let
me heal you
it doesn't matter what your past is it
doesn't matter who you are where you've
been what you've done he does not care
and his grace will abound
but just go to him
and let today be that starting point
it doesn't matter who you are where
you've been what you've done
but all that matters right now
is where you go from here god bless you
here is their relate look i don't know
anything about these two people but i
can i'm gonna read this [ __ ]
like a book so i already said i already
called this i already said i bet this
organization has
taken women who are hoes and trying to
make him feel better and bring him to
jesus and like born again virgin future
in this [ __ ] featuring this hope okay
yeah
and i guaran and he
they're both justifying their own shitty
strategies he
is a dude who can't get us can't get
[ __ ] he didn't get any [ __ ] and he's
running around saying
look how [ __ ] virtuous i am right
because i can't get any [ __ ] you should
be like me you should have still you're
trying to justify his own shitty results
she's russian wrapped in love right she
is trying to justify
her own shitty big dicks that she will
drive and is like no no no no i'm like
i'm holier than thou
like you can't [ __ ] around you woman in
the crowd i can
it's hypocritical [ __ ] i can't
[ __ ] stand yeah it is very
hypocritical absolutely absolutely
that's why i say like it's a bad like
why are we having these girls like give
the speeches because you're basically
saying girls ladies you can do whatever
you want and they'll still be a husband
waiting don't forget they're absolutely
but here's the deal there will be that's
the point but he's going to be trash
you're going to marry him
oh yeah exactly exactly you're still got
you know it's very
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
because if she would have ran into
this
[ __ ] turbo chad dude she she would
have never slept with the second or the
third or the fourth or she's not as
intelligent as you and she would have
saw the dissonance between them and the
fact that that quarterback wasn't going
to be her boyfriend
but she she thought that he really
wanted her because she's a dumbass
dumb now she's a dumb hoe i'll say ho
now
and she couldn't see the dissonance
and so she just went through the whole
team
and and now and and now
now that jesus has come into the
situation she found a new daddy because
it's the only daddy that won't leave
yeah so i have a question okay because i
i'm a very empathetic person yeah so on
one hand like i i could see like girls
are forced to make decisions a lot
younger than men you turn like 14 and 15
and you're flooded with attention yeah
there's a lot of girls that don't have
um like dads around you know what i'm
saying like to like help them filter
through guys make those decisions right
so if a girl's in a situation where that
like that's what she chose to do but she
was fit like you've done stupid [ __ ] at
15. sure right like you stupid [ __ ] now
yeah yeah and so i was like what's the
balance between like like being like i'm
not saying girls should be a born-again
virgin but it's hard because part of me
feels like girls can learn from their
mistakes because some girls just aren't
in a good situation but at the same time
being absent though
he's a weak dad half the time too yeah a
girl can have a father and he could be a
very weak man i think i think that hoes
come in all forms i think it's the wrong
information yeah i think it's the wrong
information because we raise children
in schools off of the education which is
broken and then we teach them about
love and relationships in places like
church
instead of giving them
red pill information about how we're
wired yeah like the
of human nature
is completely
like ignored and pretend we pretend like
that isn't who we are right right and
then we put this facade
on the surface of it which is which is
this kind of thing we use manipulation
tactics to try to fix it
like fear fire and brimstone etc so
what's like a girl in her situation like
because i i see both sides because like
what's a girl in her situation supposed
to do you know what i mean like look at
you just give it away for free
guys wise
i don't even blame this woman no i don't
blame her she just like she's a product
of her time i don't even blame my father
for what happened he had only
information he had
was the bible or church right
and this woman here same thing she made
all these mistakes because she didn't
have any any
any education on how it actually works
and so ad in her pursuit of finding how
it actually works this was the best
thing that she had i feel bad for her
just as much you know what but it's the
same do you think she did what she
should have done like would you say i
think she did all she could do yeah okay
like it's the same exact situation like
okay women like you take this kind of
brutally honest
uh perspective we're putting on this one
as well right yeah
and it's it's unfortunate yes i i have
sibling it's like well that sucks and it
sucks because you she can't
here's the difference between like you
can't take it you can't take the dicks
back right between a man and woman right
yeah but you look at all the guys who
kind of stumble into the red pill space
in their 40s and 50s right they've been
they've lived their whole life according
to a bad roadmap
and now that's what creates their age it
creates rage yeah but they have a choice
the man the man at least can [ __ ] do
something about it can make it better he
can actually take the next 20 years of
his life and make him [ __ ] amazing
unfortunately she can't take back the
dicks yeah but that is just an
unfortunate reality of our biological
situations they're different and like
we're not all going to get out of this
alive yeah there's there's widows and
there's losers this that's nature nature
is metal nature is metal that's an
instagram account
yeah it's badass
okay so you do think that in that
situation that's like what she should
have done it's what she did yeah you
know
what she should look like
like to me it depends how hard she is
if she can get away with it wait so if
she's super hot like if she was 30
pounds you keep holding around no no i
mean like like the born-again virgins it
only works for the hot chicks oh i see
what i'm saying
but at the same time in all fairness
um men that are allowed to cheat on
their girl only happens to the high
level dudes yeah yeah right so again it
goes back to nature's medal and life's a
[ __ ] yeah understanding the rules and
you make your own decisions i don't i
don't think this is like a bad person or
anything i think that she only had a
certain amount of information and she
had this thing that could validate all
those feelings she had towards what she
did because what's the alternative here
what is the alternative like i mean i
mean that's her i came to the bible too
exactly yeah like
for him and for her because the
alternative is to accepting reality that
you [ __ ] up and you're a loser
particularly that is the alternative
particularly no one wants to hear that
okay so but it's like pushing being a
hoe because you're building a career
based off of being a hoe
and
no no seriously so she's saying she's
saying sleep with who you want okay then
after you'll still get a husband this is
the high value guy i'm with okay and on
top of that you can make a bunch of
money travel the us talk to high
schoolers and tell them not to do what
you did even though what you did just
built your career the kind of girl who
should be leading this kind of a seminar
is like my friend's uh you know you know
what i'm talking about his wife
yeah she has she she's maybe been with
like two or three guys
and she and but always with the
intention of i want to find a husband
yeah and that was when she was like a
teenager like that
like adult boyfriends right yeah
and she's been and she'll say this
herself she's like women aren't
prepped to be
wives these days like a 16 year old girl
today isn't thinking
who am i gonna marry in two years time
yeah they're not thinking that right
they were thinking that
a few hundred years ago they absolutely
were thinking that but now they think
about it yeah you know yeah so that like
she should be like running these kind of
seminars and teaching these women like
how are you going to raise your
daughters i agree because you like yeah
you can you're probably [ __ ] up if
you're you know if you're old if you're
you know a middle-aged woman this crowd
who's coming here to for this advice
cool here's what you should do here's
how you better man for marriage now more
importantly
your daughters
you need to drill this into them from a
very very young age so that that
generational thing doesn't keep [ __ ]
happening yeah
yeah no i agree i just i i see both
sides because i want her i have a lot of
empathy for those girls but like because
i was really lucky i had a good dad and
i know that i have girls on the time all
the time on here
but i do like i do disagree like i think
girls are more likely to have make those
decisions if they don't have like a
strong masculine like father in the
picture
yeah so that makes sense to me but i
think that what you want to do is a
father and i've actually put a lot of
deep thought into this because
i've had questions come through my
instagram after i've made youtube videos
like what happens if you have a daughter
and my and i had to think about this
very deeply
and my my answer to that is i'm going to
educate her on how the world really
works yeah yeah i'm going to love her
regardless she'll be a lesbian and i'll
still love her
what i want for my daughter and my sons
is to educate them fully with the real
world knowledge of how this thing
actually works
and then i want them to take that
information and go create choice
i agree with you and if if my daughter
has all the information and she so
chooses
to be a hoe or a lesbian or
to very very meticulously vet based off
the information i've given her what what
the dude will look like the little bitty
things that she'll be able to call out
and know
then i just want her to have choice if
she wants to do the phone can party
thing
and run her notch count up to three and
then hold on whatever she wants to do
i'm gonna love her regardless but my job
is to educate her be
impactful less than more than more than
i want to be around i want to be
impactful as a father yeah and andrew
talks about this a lot and i completely
resonate with this you want to be
impactful and part of that impactfulness
is is when you're there but it's also in
the education you give her to understand
how this world really spins
and then love her through whatever
choice she deserves that she decides to
take so that's it man that's that's how
i'm going to raise my daughters
and my boys and your boys i think that's
good like i don't think parents can
control like get out get the best
outcomes like my parents are really not
controlling well a lot of parents are
because it's the only thing in their
life that they do control yeah which
makes them unqualified to to speak on
the subject anyway and they don't know
how to they don't know how to convince
their
they don't know how to set it up in such
a way that their kids don't make the
same shitty mistakes they made
they can't they have to control them out
of making a shitty choice rather than
philosophizing and explaining them have
that shitty choice it's really like
as they're trying to control them it
really pushes them away totally from
there
how many how many [ __ ] come out of
catholic schools
the number of women that i work with
because you suppress them who came from
a catholic school or a mormon upbringing
ridiculous amount of money
that's why i'm so big on salt lake bro
so many ways because here's what's
happening
they grow up and they realize the whole
thing was [ __ ] and they feel tricked
yep making up the last time now yep and
then and then it's all i don't know i
might i feel like my school wasn't like
we were always better than the public
schools we always were at the school i
went to but i have heard that a lot i've
heard it enough that i have to believe
it
but and and
another thing that catholic girls do and
muslim girls do this exact same thing as
well because they've got all they
they're the loophole is anal sex yeah
yeah we call them butthole versions oh
that was super common these girls they
take in the ass i'm like this is dumb as
[ __ ] and the irony is like that that's a
big it's an upgrade
it's like it doesn't feel as good like
let's not cheat ourselves it's like
checkpoints
we love each other so much we'll argue
about things not not to be right
individually but to win collectively oh
okay okay yeah you can
it's not comparable to normal sex where
i get it yeah it's not comparable
because it's better anyway so
okay i bet she was a butthole virgin
she got her virgin card back and then
she went around church slaying i'll tell
you what i'll say what i bet he hasn't
[ __ ] her in the butt i bet he hasn't
you know why because that dude that chad
quarterback in high school he did and
and he did it ruthlessly and she hated
it yep and now she dreams about him
well it was a great episode
so what do you guys think are we gonna
chastity moving forward for you guys did
i convince you yes i'm sorry
i've turned it in
to clarify this whole video
her end result is correct it's the means
and the why that is wrong okay what we
should tell women is explain to them
listen
if
you go sleeping with a bunch of men
god's not going to come down and throw
you in hell and burn you to death for
eternity
however
you're going to set yourself up
in a way that's not
really conducive to you finding the kind
of man the kind of having the kind of
family fulfilling happiness and the kind
of life yes exactly that you really want
and for that reason you shouldn't go
around sleeping with a bunch of men i
think actually women
i i think hoes get wiped up faster than
proof in a lot of cases
but i think the damage is more internal
because those girls can't be happy with
the guy that they have yeah they're
happy
they're leaving even if he's even if
he's a good dude like because i think a
lot of posts get end up getting like
i've seen it where they get good dudes
that like a lot of girls would be happy
to be married to but because of what
they did they just can't be happy with
him yeah so i think the damage is
exciting though like like a lot of guys
nowadays will look like they don't care
and that's sad but it's just like if i
ask guys on my show all the time would
you marry a virgin do you want a virgin
they all say no i've never had a guy say
yes
volta conversion yeah okay you guys
would be the first all day why wouldn't
you why would i don't want to take a
potion while we can i i agree with you
i'm like
i think it's best if like both are very
like just personal i think
i completely disagree
statistically like that's the the
longest you think it's best for a man to
be a virgin i think
because i don't think i don't i don't
think
really quickly i don't think a virgin
man
okay these days right i don't think a
virgin man
has
the wherewithal the knowledge about
women the charm necessary to attract a
virgin woman well i wouldn't even add to
that and say the woman's not attracted
to a virgin man
well that's the exact same reason right
but he's got no game so is the longest
marriages are between two virgins like
that's like statistically if you want to
like run the numbers by whose marriage
is last week but marriage is very
clearly a failure in society
well it's an absolute [ __ ] failure it
built society it built society but now
the controversy now we have laws the
contract has been now we have laws
and we and we still use
um
let's say female energy as men
to go out and build things in the world
that was in the beginning we're hitting
each other with clubs and [ __ ] and
stabbing each other's swords now we just
send people to prison for killing or
raping or whatever
so we have something that has kind of
replaced it
and it is also my opinion that the
reason that the left
like wants to put a
a gap in between us because my beef is
is not with family it's just that
marriage is [ __ ] but if they put a
gap between us now we have twice the
workers and twice the tax income for a
country and every country is a business
so yeah cat food and box one how big
dressing yeah and twitter
okay so the best contender so you're
you're gonna be chased from that one now
i'm about to ladies ladies stay out of
the dm i'll take no i'll take the virgin
card as well let's do it together yeah
virginia okay so you guys are born again
virgins we came in virgins oh okay
um it's cause it's cause we only do anal
you only stick it in a voice but yeah
i'm very i'm very happy for you guys
thank you
i feel cleansed
shout out to the show um why don't you
tell the people where they can find both
of your channels
uh you can find me at jaywaller on
youtube
jaywaller7 on instagram
and
waller7j on twitter
and you can find me
still in cooper just search for that on
youtube
s-t-i-r-l-i-n-g you say you spell my
name you'll find me on the first when it
comes up and on instagram i'm at cooper
sterling the other way around and then
on twitter i'm at sterling wisdom
okay guys thank you so much guys for
coming on um appreciate it thank you for
watching guys you already know the deal
if you've watched two or more of my
videos and you do not subscribe we have
beef okay b that is not cool a subscribe
is free so hit that subscribe button
like the video on your way way out and i
will talk to you guys next time wait you
gotta be like ah